ready
actually put me the son
can kind of put it right here so you
know these notes do that yeah ready
all right afternoon officer Damon Miller
public information office will tell us
Police Department
imagine to see you our interim chief of
police Steve outlaw all right good
afternoon guys thanks for sticking
around for the release at approximately
33 this morning the consolidated
dispatched agency received a call
Vietnam would one of a stabbing that was
occurring in the workplace in the
workplaces dike industries at 2:01 one
Maryland circle and so as officers
arrived they were able to attract the
suspect as his description had been
released to him and they were able to
encounter and engage a suspect and take
him into custody
almost immediately upon arrival at the
location here the gentleman's name the
suspects name is Antoine Demetrius Brown
41 years old I'm sorry to meet are
Antoine a en TWA in in Demetrius de m ET
are i s brown BR o w in and again 41
years old and I would like to also note
some of the heroic actions as we
understand it at this point guys is very
preliminary information that we've got
that upon the gentleman leaving the
effort he stabbed his coworkers
upon leaving that several employees
armed themselves with whatever they
could and try to engage them and
actually held him at bay at one point
while officers were arriving and then he
again started his his flight upon which
time the officer took him into custody
as far as we know there is no employment
issues that were pending or that he knew
about yes mr. brown is employee from
what we understand again this is very
preliminary approximately three and a
half months he clocked in at eight
o'clock this morning he was engaged in
some kind of a dispute at work he was
told to clock out he clocked out at 8:20
and then we received a call at the CDA
at approximately 33 no sir I do not know
nor know nor was mr. brown was he
injured also was not denied we do not
know it's our understanding it was a
smaller probably a common pocketknife
type size there was no physical dispute
reported it appeared to be just verbal
only with co-workers or supervisors we
don't know that at this point we'll have
to defer that to tell a some immoral
health care yes everybody who's been
emitted or patients and they can give a
more accurate accounting of their status
as we stand here now no he is being
interviewed no we have no known or
reported injuries on suspect he was
challenged by a police officer who
arrived and they took him into custody
it was close by within about a block
from here from my understanding from
this first IV to his apprehension how
long does that day
I don't have that information at this
point we can get that will release at a
later point was it about 10 minutes 15
minutes half an hour it was probably 10
to 15 minutes I'm gonna guess they
arrived within four minutes of being
dispatched supervisors please at all we
don't have that at this time he from
what we know now
he appeared that he was actually had
sought out certain victims as they were
not on a particular line as he was
departing the workplace no we don't have
this
well what kind of have to separate that
you know we were actually at the city's
9/11 ceremony memorial ceremony at
station 16 near the public safety
complex and so it was right in the
middle of ceremony that I was actually
notified of that and we had responding
officers coming and and that was all
City responding officers that's Fire
Department police department then the
County EMS and so you can't help but
wonder on the first blush when you hear
that
is this related to the to the
anniversary you just can't help but
wonder that very very sad occasion and
so all of our responding officers
they're also very cognizant of what day
this is again you can't help but wonder
but fortunately from what we can tell
there's no relationship to the
anniversary and where he moved
throughout the building
you know what he's asking if we have a
timeline of the exact sequence of events
we don't have that yet the our
investigators will be talking and
continuing their interviews with all the
victims and other witnesses that we're
not assaulted or battered in this case
and so they can go fine-tune that
timeline the best they can if there's
any kind of surveillance cameras etc
they'll try to piece that together but
we don't have that at this point so see
without the specific people I mean the
how his movements that he go around
searching from death to deaths or from
one part of the building to another
looking for those victims yes my
understanding is you have an interoffice
thing you have a large warehouse area
where things were assembled it again it
appears that he did not go on a straight
path to leave the workplace that he may
have sought out either a certain offices
or certain people we don't have those
dynamics
well we know that he clocked out at 8:20
this morning and then I know that we
received the phone call or the see they
receive the first phone call at
approximately 33 and so where was he at
was did he yet
did he call somebody was he trying to
get a ride we don't know what he was
doing in those 10 12 13 minutes between
when he clocked out and when he engaged
his victims
yeah and before I get to that let me
kind of set the stage with our partner
responding agencies that have been just
instrumental in this whole thing because
it's going to answer that you know we
had dolly TPD he had TF tell us the fire
department we had Leon County EMS
arrived we had the you know once they
transferred him in to the hospital tmh
has been absolutely fantastic in helping
us to sort out the number of injuries
because we know we only know what we do
know regarding injured people we
encounter a lot of the issues like this
to where people self transport not only
to that hospital or to another hospital
or sometimes they may get it injured and
go home and say I'm done with work and
realize I've been injured and I'll
report it tomorrow and so but tmh has
been fantastic in their mergency
department on helping to triage sort out
the victims they were very instrumental
in a unification plan with the arriving
families of the victims that could be
seen by their families based on their
condition we are other law enforcement
partners between the FBI FDLE
LCS oh just very tremendous helping here
secure an original crime scene going to
his house and help him secure that for
an individual search of his house
that happens in almost all incidents
when you have multiple multiple victims
it is a very common place because they
may get a victim in they think came from
this scene but it's actually none
related and so that is that is very
common to happen that's why we're
initial reports you know we'll put out
multiple victims and then we try to
fine-tune that to make sure that this
victim is related to this and also
sometimes you get victims that have
primary wounds from the suspect then you
have victims that have secondary wounds
as they were trying to escape not by the
suspect and so again sometimes it takes
a while for the murky room personnel our
investigators to sort through which
injuries are related to what action no
ma'am I do not
can you go more into detail but you were
talking about I don't have the details
the the very preliminary information was
the fact that some of the employees as
he was leaving
you know armed themselves whatever they
could sticks or whatever they had
building materials they have inside and
it actually held him at bay at what
point of wish momentarily
that delayed his escape which is very
good for us again but he got up started
to leave again at at some point the
officer engaging they took one
apparently when they when they held him
the bay they have the head him on the
ground now he had already left his
co-workers and has started his travel
away from here again no it was a way it
was probably with a block why can't you
tell us where I don't know all that will
still be determined yes ma'am
[Music]
no ma'am we do not have a motor that's
why we bring out our other partners at
the federal level FBI in the state to
find out there's any other background of
concern and we we have no other
background of concern at this point you
you're gonna be better served by going
to the website and they appeared to make
construction and building materials
doors and windows now what they make of
this site I really couldn't tell you he
appears to be they've been interviewing
for a while Natalie I do not know the
status of interview we're not going to
interrupt the interview and we just let
it go let it play out he was going after
and why we don't know motive yeah there
is nothing to indicate that he was
giving an indication of his plans or his
motives or anything else yet now as far
as we know is spontaneous
yeah that'll probably continue to occur
at the police department no ma'am no
once we transfer there again they're
patient they go into the side of the
hospital there they enjoy patient status
and so that's where we kind of leave
that one I do not know I'm gonna make
the presumption yeah because we will
have a presence here as a crime scene
for quite a long time trying to
determine path in sequence of events and
so I'm gonna venture say not not
stepping this out building myself I'm
gonna say that's probably very
disruptive to their daily operations and
it probably is shut down know our city
manager's office
our mayor commissioners they're very
supportive as to what do we need
we need to be on alert right now no we
do not get a very good question thanks
for the opportunity but no all the the
actions that we have had this weekend
the first one up in Brittany estates
that we don't have the motive Lynette
that's still under active investigation
you know the unfortunate incident with
the theater they were acquaintances and
then the the shooting at the community
center
they were also acquaintances and that
was deemed to be an accident and then
this appears to be completely isolated
also spontaneously we don't know that
would lead it to a motive and we don't
have a motive and again somebody had
asked about aftercare for the fascias in
the families you know that is very
detrimental to families you know we get
a phone call from your family where that
you're injured or maybe somebody calls
their behalf and so we have a whole unit
of victim advocates that were specially
trained to provide these services and so
they were actively engaged with our
victims families tmh has a very dynamic
core of victim advocates and case
managers also that do the same thing
we've had our other partners in local
area between L CSO and the FBI that can
also provide victim advocacy systems
where as needed and that has been
offered and it's very much appreciated
it is because you come back to work
every day as maybe an impacted co-worker
or maybe somebody who wasn't impacted
and the day the time you walk into work
that next morning that's a trigger point
and so you can't help but have a
flashback of what occurred the previous
day and this will always be an
anniversary day for some of the
co-workers so always remember this day
and said so we have to be very cognizant
that and when we recognize on advocacy
work you know we do the best we can to
to provide immediate consoling as needed
but also to help them get plugged into
other resources in the community other
counseling services again because we you
know we write our reports we go home we
we do reflect on it because very much of
tragedy but in those folks lives data
they can't shut it off when we turn our
reports in and so you're very correct
you know that this they're going to be
thinking and being haunted by this to
various degrees everybody processes
tragedy differently and so there's going
to be many that do need and deserve some
aftercare and that we want to be in a
position to help point them in the right
direction and get them linked up with
what they can use
but when officers arrived yeah promoted
again how you qualify flee walking
running we don't have this particular
jet you know but at some point employees
tried to engage in to slow him down or
to stop him he stopped briefly at one
point and then he started his travels
again to leave and at that point then
the officers arrived in yes well it is
safe you know we do just as the police
as the as the lead agency in the whole
community as a police agency we hear
those comments all the time we get asked
those same questions is this a safe
community I don't have to live here it
is a safe community and I tell people
all the time as long as you're typically
speaking and again there's not a cookie
cutter response to this but as long as
you're not dealing in dope selling dope
or trying to steal somebody else's dope
generally speaking you're in a safe
you're the safe community people most of
these crimes most of them not all but
most their acquaintances crimes they
know the other person and that's where I
just have to kind of leave that yes I
already did the first name or last name
Antoine a in TWA in and we think that
one has to as to it
what's most seriously injured
in this wreck you know I don't know I
don't know anybody's roles or positions
in the corporate level or the company
again well when it comes to the police
response we're gonna have a footprint
here for most the day again just trying
to piece together the timelines and
sequence of events collecting evidence
because you're gonna have evidence that
could be almost anywhere you know
they've already started they already
canvass the neighborhood for other
security cameras you know that we can
gain that footage to help be a critical
piece to the puzzle of the sequence of
this and so at some point when we're
done with ours you know we'll work with
a corporation in the company and we'll
say we're done and then it'll be up to
them to figure out what they want to do
for their operations in most larger
corporations and this appears to have a
big pretty big footprint on the website
you know we do have other resources they
can garner on behalf of their employees
I do not that this will be something
they're working out based on again the
motive intent what he says in the
interview
he does have some history some of it is
older some related to some some element
about violence coming out of Georgia in
about a year between a year and two
years ago that we can tell and but
that's probably most for recent history
okay all right thank you very much
we don't have a plan unless something
just significant